welcome back on the show I'm thrilled to
have you back here it's been a while
because he was promoting Luke Cage as he
was Luke Cage that last time he was here
but now he's in the the new film
breakthrough that is the first of 20th
Century Fox film to be distributed by
the Walt Disney studio motion pictures
the none other than the man himself Mike
Colter in this movie that is available
in theaters near you coming up this very
week on Wednesday April 17th good to see
you sir how are you good to see you too
man what's going on with you you're just
traveling all over the country you know
making into meat man you know bouncing
around doing a couple films breakthrough
is the one that are currently promoting
that's right opened this week yesterday
I just realized I said that it's coming
in soon to a theater near you and I gave
a date that was yesterday well no work
two shows yesterday Mike I'm a little
bit of the audience is smart I think
they picked up on it like it's new
you're starting yesterday they broke
through yesterday so you are a fan of
the Lakers but I know we had this
conversation you also are partial to the
Warriors yeah yeah well so let's start
let's start with the Lakers first what
the hell I call this I mean I've never
called it a sitting on the air but you
know when the Lakers made a big move I
felt like you know this was possible
because the West is very different it
was gonna be a rebuilding stage there's
a lot of things from the management need
to be fixed you they were trying to do
something that you know you can't just
fix it with Kobe left it was really it's
a mentality it's a sort of it's sort of
a it's the thing they have to recut a
revamp and I think that's gonna take
them a while well I mean obviously you
know what happened with Magic Johnson
was just an absolute I think I think I
think ultimately he took the fall
because first there was you know there
was the lay off and the rest for some
some of the stars you know we'll leave
it that way well I mean yeah I mean the
team didn't finish the season because
they got hurt the understand yeah that
and then you know the rest of them just
you know does it they shut it down
and magic I think the Luke Walton thing
I don't think magic was co-signing on
that I think magic felt like maybe that
that was the right coach
but other people huh probably didn't
want that and so he felt like if I give
in to this I may as well leave because
we're all free often
the wrong direction it's an interesting
tale so do you think here's the issue is
that who's gonna come as a free agent to
come team up with LeBron with everything
that's going on just like this yeah I
think I think there will be some people
who will be interested but would be the
people that he wants you know who's
gonna take off take the load off and I
think that's the question I mean I think
there's like two or three people that he
probably would want and I don't think
any of those players are gonna you don't
think Durant's coming huh no I don't
think well I mean why why don't why
would he my whole point
and my culture here on the Rich Eisen
show that I've been talking about here
on the show with Chris and everybody
else that's been calling in is I don't
know why Durant would leave Golden State
there's no reason there's no reason
other than the fact that everybody
thinks that he has to put a stamp on his
own team with his own man that that his
legacy is he joined the team that he
couldn't be and and needs to beat all
those write his own legacy people who at
home are sitting there going well that's
great but you can't do this they said
it's anything about Colby he does
nothing to prove to anybody he went from
a great team to another great team and
with the pressure on he still came out
as the MVP of that Finals I believe you
in a row two in a row is that's pretty
impressive because of spotlights on you
and they saleable the spotlights on you
can you show
well the spotlight was on him there was
there was no reason from the lose and he
did exactly what he was supposed to do
crush it finished it right and what do
you exactly like everybody's like well
let's see what you can do here in the
sidecar he'd just be the sidekick and he
was actually in the superhero it's a
very you know organic team he comes in
curry wasn't a hundred percent
physically and and they organically
flowed and he's a mismatch for anybody
right the ball went to him and he took
advantage now are you saying that Durant
needs to say because Steph Curry's an
executive producer on your film oh you
know that's a good point I think that's
a good boy there's a good tie in that's
a good tire that's a good time that's
that thing just you know I just want to
make sure that that there's no yeah
that's a good one I like always make
things aware of my that's a good point
listeners in view I think Durant's the
best plane in the game right now and I
know people will try to figure whose
best game
he says Kobe hung it up I thought he was
but the biggest mismatch for anybody he
can dribble he can shoot he can he can
do anything he wants to do with the ball
yeah he's a bit
but I mean he defends well I just can't
there's no weaknesses it's a big game
the night here in Los Angeles though
Clippers I mean if the Clippers can
somehow somehow squeeze another well
justice yes
string another one together uh-huh where
then it would have to be at least a six
game series uh-huh that you know that
the series would have to return to Los
Angeles regardless of what happens now
putting the pressure on the team for
Sunday hmm that's that's what I'm trying
to paint the the rosiest picture for the
Clippers I think the onus State you know
it's good for them to get tested early
and I think their biggest opponent is
themselves because they've done so well
they have so much firepower they have to
get motivated for games and I think
sometimes it takes a wake-up call I
think Clips squeezing one the second
game is a really good thing for them
mentally and I think people go back to I
think curry talked about Tigers Tigers
come back mean degrees come back then
people came back a courage oh I saw I
said yeah but different they forget that
dream on was taken out of the series for
one game that was that was sort of that
wasn't normal so I don't know yeah and
then to bring this conversation full
circle mike colter here on the Rich
Eisen show again breakthrough as already
in theaters near you and we'll get to
that in a second is that is that yes
there was something strange about
draymond Green you know strange it was
it was an outlier right when when when
he hit when he hit King James and the
crown jewels cost him a game yeah with
the talent about yeah and he watched and
he watched the A's with Marshawn Lynch
that night or just across the way when
there was that game five that went down
and then they lost the whole series
eventually mm-hmm but that's why Durant
is crucial yeah and that's why he's not
just a sidecar guy who just joined the
team that he's there now and one guy
goes down like say Oh boogie cousins
it's not going to be the end of the
world
because he's part of the mix here that's
why it's crucial that's why his legacy
is totally secured I don't view him as a
guy who's just created a super team and
needs to start something else somewhere
else I don't understand it not at all I
think this is people who who want bigger
personalities right he's a guy that goes
about his business and he doesn't really
care for the extras he doesn't want to
talk about where is he gonna go and undo
all these ideas about you know you know
what's he gonna do next he goes out
there and he slays and he goes back and
that's it I think people want too much
from basketball players not every
basketball player wants to be an
entertainer as well well I don't know if
you're a golfer as well but I did see
you peripherally when I started talking
about you know Jim Nantz is joining me
about the Tiger Woods win and you just
brought it up as well I mean do you play
are you know a little mixed to a golf
course and I mean I have been planning
to play but you know there's two young
kids and and trying to work it just like
I mean yeah it's very difficult but did
you did you watch it do you have any I
watched portions of it and and every
time Tiger played I I'd be interested I
sort of sure tuned in I was like
everybody else I remember 2008 I was
flying to LA from New York and I
remember him winning the Masters then I
think was his last time yes it was
before that and and I remember thinking
when this whole thing happened I thought
his golf is such a mental mental game I
didn't think about the physical injuries
I thought it would be very difficult for
him to get back to his to his prime
because of his mental focus you know all
the distractions in time sort of I think
is as sort of redirected him and I think
that's that's the biggest part of it has
anyone ever told you in your career that
you can't or you won't
oh yeah sure I mean I mean not enough
though I will say that not enough I've
had to sort of you know create my own
you know my own chips to you know to
sort of what do you mean by not enough
for you know a lot of people you know
they they're from the outset they are
the antithesis of what people would
think of as successful in any in certain
things like if you're an athlete you're
too short for the sport they'll tell you
well you're hearing that for calamari
who's gonna be the number one overall
pick in the draft
exactly tonight exactly I'm sure he uses
that to motivate himself right great
trains right but when you're a guy like
me sometimes they go oh yeah you can
make it now you got to find out you got
to find Drive you know you got to find
your own Drive because someone telling
you can make it that's not really
helpful sometimes you know right so you
got to come up with something that's
gonna you know help you keep going so
tell me about breakthrough what do
people need to know about this film it's
a family film first and foremost I mean
religion aside I think it's a good story
for people who who are who are faithful
and who have an undying devotion to to
believing in the miracles because it is
a miracle I mean you talk about the
percentages of is happening to happen to
anyone
well there's orange somebody who
some young man who fell through the ice
yeah about 20 minutes and then he
recovered him my character um was a
first responder recovered him about 25
more minutes and he had didn't have any
vital signs and and his mother refused
to give up on him and she kept praying
and miraculously he made a full recovery
and there's not one sign of any damage
of his brain or anything it's
unbelievable so you're you're playing
the first responder who was first on
this Rosanna Xenia and who without who's
obviously a hard work and dedication
that the miracle would never have have
happened did you meet the actual
individual that I did I did Tommy Shawn
I met him at the PIPA mirror and yeah so
you didn't meet him before no he was in
Missouri you know um the script it was
pretty solid as far as that and we
talked to you know the real the real
mother the real the real kid the real
pastor people who were who were there we
didn't get a chance to meet him but um
but I talked to him in the premier and
yeah he was really pleased with the
movie yeah it's I mean again the cast is
great your aunt at Topher Grace Dennis
Haysbert who's been on this show before
you probably shared some if you talk to
any warrior stuff with him he's yeah
he's missing we went to the game to hold
the whole cast went up to a box I mean
we saw the Warriors um beat up on the
Lakers
yeah actually was a game yeah I mean the
Lakers at oh so where's that lay down oh
yeah where is that Lee yeah Lakers at
warriors was the end of the season
essentially on Christmas Day yeah LeBron
what was that what did we say it was it
was this boy seven-minute mark of the
third quarter Chris yeah correct yeah
third quarter Lakers destroying the
Warriors on Christmas Day in front of
the whole country
mm-hmm as they were I think at their
high watermark of like seven games above
500 yeah yeah and then LeBrons growing
gave way and then the I mean what he's
down usually injury free I mean that's
one thing else except for had any
injuries not nagging injuries which is
gonna be a test I mean yeah all athletes
have to go through this so well he has
to bounce back and you know
a weird you know I don't know anything
about those and then before I let you go
I do want to ask you about Luke Cage now
that obviously it's off of Netflix and
Disney mm-hmm is now picking everything
up is it possible they pick Luke Cage oh
well this is kind of creating their own
thing right now they already know a few
shows right they got their own content I
mean anything's possible
I don't necessarily know that it's a
Disney um vehicle like as far as a tone
but you know anything is possible they
own it right after a certain what at a
certain points right rules have to wait
and see is it something you'd be
interested in my answer the phone you
know I'm working other stuff but I don't
know that oh yeah yeah cuz obviously you
know last time you were here to promote
in it crashed
Netflix yeah when it when it debuted hmm
so there's fans that one listen there's
no fans I want to see what's gonna
happen to third season I think that's
where we wanted to take your story
complete it and that would be nice to
give the fans something that's like
complete but right it's also good
leaving one more so of course I
understand it well which athletes have
come up to you to talk about this sort
of stuff any anybody that we would know
drop some names that came up to you
wanted it was a doll store game I played
an all-star um celebrity game last last
went in was in Charlotte okay she has
meet quite have quite a few of the
basketball you know and I was fans fans
a lot of Hall of Famers you know like
Gary Payton and you know and old guys
like Dennis Scott Shaq came up Berkeley
you know these are guys you know I
watched place I was really happy that's
great I can't just coming at Cheney
Bichette was on the plane coming out
with me how'd you do in the game I did
pretty well I think a double-double at
1111 something like that you know on
yeah I wasn't wasn't bad I wasn't I
wasn't I was one of those guys out there
do you know happy to just run the floor
stuff I then I saw they they weren't
gonna play any setup no defense really
they were gonna kick it down the low and
Lena worked work it inside out they
weren't doing it there's rundown shoot
coming back I've never played in that
game but I could have told you that how
do you think Kevin Hart is one MVPs
there's not it's not through the exes no
justice well my first shot was a bank
shot three I'll put it that way
no I call it but nobody heard
answer great answer hey Mike come back
anytime you want please you really
appreciate having you here again
breakthrough is in theaters right now
across the country on April 17th is when
it opened up it's based on the Christian
novel the impossible and it stars in
part this man Mike Colter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app